STEPHANIE WONG:
Today, we are talking
about diversity and inclusion,
a highly available storage
launch, and a frequently
requested training.
This is Stephanie Wong,
and welcome to "This Week
in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Diversity, equity,
and inclusion--
DEI-- are more than
just buzzwords.
They are critical components
of workplace culture
that have real, tangible impacts
on your entire organization.
Not only because it
enhances your ability
to be responsive to
users and customers,
but because it builds trust
and a sense of belonging
for your employees.
Read our short
ebook to learn steps
you can take to build
DEI into your business,
along with insights from
our journey at Google Cloud.
We recently announced
Filestore Enterprise,
a fully-managed, cloud-native
NFS solution that lets you
confidently deploy critical
file-based applications
in Google Cloud, backed
by a service level
agreement that delivers
99.99% regional availability.
To get started with
Filestore Enterprise,
register for our
webinar, Explore
What's New with Google
Cloud Storage, on October 6,
and Google Cloud Next
INF206 breakout session,
where you'll hear from real
users about their modernization
journey.
You asked for it
and we listened.
We're excited to announce the
Cloud Digital Leader learning
pathway, our first offering
for business professionals
that includes both
training and certification.
The Cloud Digital
Leader learning
pathway is designed to skill
up individuals and teams that
work with technical
Google Cloud practitioners
so they can contribute to
strategic, cloud-related
business decisions.
Check out the blog to
learn more and sign up.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
then check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.